hey youtubers is Charlie hopefully you
guys have all had a chance to watch and
process the arrow midseason finale so
many WTF s because Rachael is such a big
deal this season I wanted to do a video
about my top 5 favorite stories ones
that I think are important for arrow and
explain the Lazarus Pit for people that
haven't read the comics the characters
appeared in over 500 issues and not all
of them were Batman titles he appeared
in Justice League birds of prey most of
the best ones have been Batman stories
though so when I made my list I tried to
pick things that I think are gonna be
relevant to what's happening on the show
so just general spoiler warning for
everything on the show so far but
starting with my top 5 Rachael old
stories number 5 tales of the demon the
collected edition this is a really big
collection of a bunch of stories about
ratio goal so it's almost like a
catch-all it covers everything from the
first appearance of Talia the
introduction of Rashad Ghul and Batman
232 just a lot of the biggest classic
ratio gold stories you should be able to
find it for a discount on comiXology
or at your comic book store number 4
death in the maidens
this is a Greg Rucka story it's really
trippy it talks about racial ghouls time
working with the Nazis it also has a lot
of nyssa backstory and her escape from
Auschwitz Batman even gets to talk to
his mother in the afterlife think about
how trippy that is they might use some
of this story on arrow if Stephen Amell
is gonna be near the edge of death we
might get some awesome all of our dream
sequences so look out for that number 3
the Tower of Babel this is a really
awesome Justice League story that people
point to Batman develops all these
methods for taking down his friends if
they get out of control and the
information on everyone's weaknesses
like all the Justice League members
weaknesses falls into the hands of
Rachel and Talia it's just really
awesome to learn Batman's battle plans
against Superman Wonder Woman like all
the big heroes number two the birth of
the demon trilogy as the name implies
this is the origin story of racial goal
you really can't get better than that
but you learn all about how he found
that Lazarus pits how I started using
them what his family was like before he
became the demons head it is at a print
right now but you might be able to find
it on comiXology and my number one
racial goals story the daughter of the
demon this was the introduction to reach
out goal in the comics like the first
time he appeared I've been talking about
it for the last couple of weeks but it's
the story that they adapted in Batman
the demon's quest
fool tries to ascertain whether or not
Batman's a worthy heir for his empire I
will completely flip my if arrow
ends up doing this if at the end of this
season
like episode 23 in the finale regional
ghoul or maybe an episode before that
asks Oliver to take over his empire to
take over the League of Assassins that
would be amazing I don't think it's
gonna happen
I mean Oliver would never leave his
friends but still just think about it
and think about how awesome it is that
arrow is getting all the best Batman
stories that just gives you an idea of
how successful the show is and what the
network thinks of it if it lets them do
those kinds of things if there are any
racial ghoul stories that you guys
really like or any favorites you have
that I didn't talk about just write them
below in the comments
now just to explain the Lazarus pin a
little more racial goals origin story
explains that he found the pits as a
young man completely by accident while
trying to save a Prince's life he was
completely healed but as a side effect
left completely insane and ended up
killing races wife race ended up getting
framed for the murder and given the
death sentence of being forced to wander
to the desert he found help and
eventually began to use the Lazarus pits
over and over there have been different
versions of the pit different spins on
it for instance once they found
something called the fountain of essence
that had slightly different effects it
healed race after he'd been dead for an
extremely long period of time
he didn't go insane but he came back in
this really old feeble body normally you
have to be dead for less than a year for
the pit to work and you're pretty much
guaranteed to go insane after you come
back at least for a little while Batman
used that same pit while he had minor
wounds though it D aged him a little so
not too bad there another character was
with them he tried to use it while he
was fully healed and was killed
instantly
so not all the pits are the same but
usually when someone refers to the
Lazarus Pit they're talking about the
traditional ones and yes there are many
of them all over the world there was
even a period where Batman had Bane
traveled all around trying to destroy
them so race wouldn't be able to keep
healing himself but as expected there
were a bunch of hidden ones they never
found normally when people think about
them they're really special and
something that racial Google guards
really closely but there have actually
been a lot of different comic book
characters that have used the pits Black
Canary used one to restore her canary
cry powers and her ability to bear
children
Nissa of the comics used them to stay
young and warped Talia's mind
she'd kill her and then just heal her
over and over again to brainwash her
remember they drive you insane when you
come back Lady Shiva Dick Grayson the
Riddler and Mr Freeze have all taken
advantage because arrow is really
conservative without they do superpowers
it's possible we could see a twist on
the idea of Resurrection with Oliver's
character he did seem like he should
have died when he tumbled off that cliff
but we seen the promo for episode 10
someone is approaching his body so
clearly he's coming back they're not
gonna kill off Stephen Amell he's not
going away what I think is gonna happen
is someone's just gonna nurse him back
to health using some extra powerful
techniques I don't think we're gonna see
a traditional Lazarus Pit but I do think
we'll get Easter eggs for it the show
will acknowledge it even if they
sidestep comic book things they usually
try to reference them in some way
they're not gonna do racial Ghul without
referencing the Lazarus Pit but don't
expect to see all of her bathing in
green fire anytime soon a lot of people
have pointed to Malcolm merlyn's
necklace here the green vial maybe being
a potential Easter Egg for the pit like
he has restorative waters in it it's
possible he's the person we've seen the
promo and he'll save Oliver as a way to
repay him for wiping his debt with the
league although technically I think he
would have had to kill rage to wipe his
debt people were saying that John
Barrowman was making comments about
filming episode 9 and he said he was in
a very cold windy place implying that he
was filming scenes on that mountaintop
set since we didn't see him in the
episode the evidence just points to him
being the person right here and he'll
appear in episode 10 so here is my
second big question for you guys do you
think that Malcolm Merlyn is gonna be
the person to save Oliver I will be
doing a Q&A for this so leave all your
questions about the Lazarus Pit racial
ghouls stories
Oliver coming back I'll post it tomorrow
sometime so be sure to subscribe to get
it
I have to say arrow probably the best
comic book show on TV right now the
flash is off to a great start some of
the other comic book shows like Gotham
agents of shield they are doing better
but they're still not quite as good as
air on my mind I feel like arrow just
has some better comic book writers on
staff and they've had longer to perfect
their formula because so much awesome
stuff has been happening maybe you guys
have missed some of it I'll do some
roundup videos next week just to make
sure everyone's caught up on all the
comic book shows right now if you're on
your mobile phone or on a tablet you can
click up here for extra links it's
either up here up here they keep
changing the place but it's the same as
the links over here so click here to
catch up on arrow
and click here to catch up on the flash
thank you so much for watching so let's
all high-five I will see you guys
tomorrow
you